bella tutti i ragazzi porca vacca
benvenuti ciao ragazzi sul lancio lei di
ho deciso di riportare body horror
questa queste quest'estate un po di
horror un po boscheri old style sliac
allora non ho visto ancora niente se non
un paio di scream che mi hanno
abbastanza inquietato della nuova destra
ora devo fare atti puoi scegliere il
play madonna belli sembrano i personaggi
di house party è orribile questa tanti
tipi praticamente si potrebbe giocare
addirittura online difficulty norma va
bene
ruba dieci pagine per le risposte ai
risultati dell'esame sembro io e la
patente non l'ho fatta così attenzioni
creed drinks quando siamo in america beh
questa cosa potrei comunque lunch lei tu
fai finta mette ko breve vede sarah in
una scuola di notte ma bellissima sala
attenzione ho trovato la pagina delle
risposte finali va bene non si torna
indietro sbloccato achievement va bene
santoni io cos'è quella roba più lì a
porta a porta [ __ ]
no dai ragazzini in questa roma
ho una padella se notiamo consorziale
arrivederci ma cosa devo fare
aiuto non capisco è chiusa la porta a
chiave altri questo qualche gioco è lo
capire da dove esce per poi uscire io
dall'altra parte però problema che non
capisco non capisco dove dovrebbe andare
la tizia perché non come faccia
prevedere le sue mosse make it a cielo
già va bene è stato solo uno possa
averne altre parti ne ho trovata una su
dieci è un punteggio un po di merda cioè
nel senso almeno una in più del cacchio
sento veramente passi la cosa non mi
piace per niente
ci provo
arrivederci era un potente altra pagina
datata pagina l'escalation e scuole sco
vesco un cazzo magari pasticcere stesso
questa forma muoviti ma va da qualche
parte
fai qualcosa come lo uso il markit forse
lo tritata attenzione attenzione il trip
l'ing il dribbling del favi che non
trovo altre pagine però rimaniamo così
che poi sono difficili da vedere quello
che ho fatto e sono stato un ruolo in
una stanza l'ho vista dopo un ora
comunque non riesco a capire porta
[Applauso]
mangiato pesante non è tanto amore fosse
una scala va allora del bello che sono
sul 26 piani di scuola che ne so io ma
quindi notte ma che è una una sala di
musica comunque non so dove tra le altre
pagine ragazzi sto girando da un'ora e
mezza le pagine di musica canzoni di
michael jackson mai rilasciate questa
una chiave trovato qualche casa che ci
sono il gioco ci ho trovato due chiavi
la chiave n la chiave c
se facciamo tutto l'alfabeto di chiavi
ce ne sono ancora un po da trovare mi sa
però se lei sta lì sotto non stati sotto
questo stavo dicendo
quindi dipende dipende dove prendo le
pagine qui cambia piano la zia a piacere
non di qua non di qua non ci facciamo
una cantata io e te a in soli usi così
come per troy e gabriella papa una
relazione veramente una roba più brutta
che abbia mai visto di qualità porta sta
portata non sono anche dove stiamo
andando a lei scopo le pagine però
attenzione problema grosso che ha
servito incastrati su angolo e per
tornare indietro
bella incazzata allo 06 che fai che ogni
volta e pastore sembra un sogno
ogni volta il nostro verso porca vacca
dall'altra parte garris aiuto non c'era
niente qua perché sono perché sono
venuto di quattro madonna garante è le
padelle tela lanci del cubo se la porta
la in fondo è accessibile dalle scale di
sopra ma attenzione però l'ho aperta ok
mancano sei pagine ragazzo un sacco cioè
la porta barca 6 preoccupate bisogno di
parlare non ora no per carità me la sto
passando da dio
non vedo quali problemi dovrei avere a
frequentare pascolati non ne vedo
neanche uno il problema tutto a posto
chi ti dice che sono preoccupato ha
esatto dentro chiuri a volta e poi muori
non è vero che mi ha colpito una padella
aiuta
non ci credo non mi ha visto quanto
rincoglionita da 1 milione questo non
troppo neanche una pace quando ce n'è
anche una pagina visto bella pulita alla
cucina caffè machine cose ma ci ho che
bello non che io apprezzarsi così tanto
il cibo della mensa scolastica è però
vero c'è un limite comunque
è fatta da tutti portanova che si
velocissimo velocissima ma di che poi le
mattinate un pugno alla colonna ma che
fare con i nonni o la grinta ne vado
me ne vado ci sono cinque pagine sto
morendo ma cosa fa dove ha già anche la
sweet da quanto quante chiacchiere fatto
esistono già impossibile ragazze la
stessa mappe uguali e la quella di prima
è la stessa mappa manca mai picchiando
scelgono le altre cinque pagine do
stavano esattamente nove c'è qualcosa
che non mi torna il tuo gioco
1 quest'altro correggetemi se sbaglio
più vai avanti più difficile nel senso
più statica corre che la metà basta
vado di sopra a nonna che scico proprio
cagati addosso a sto punto non so per
quanto mi riguarda poi anche prendere 5
al 6 all'esame che si per forza capito
nel senso calmati asciugasse la
caffetteria di st 18 st lì sotto ha
posto al posto a posto 3 ok famoso
umberto porla guarda pagina che non è
stati endo esegua lanciato porta qua
questa pagina attenzione proprio lui
proprio lui una sega che la tipa sta qua
fuori però non entrano certo che una
pagina in cucina la vedo dura per ora
eccola qua invece perfetto 5 10
attenzione
eccola qui zaidi e aiuto porca [ __ ] è
la sia la zia la zia fate gazebo madonna
si jesino ti danno davvero ha detto l'ho
chiuso la porta
faccio giro madonna come ho fatto
come ho fatto a scappare non so mancano
quattro pagine se la matematica l'ho
studiata quindi piscina come far
arrivare in piscina ma vabbè dove
cacchio sta roba
un'altra pagina 7 mi piace la tipa
arrotato vabbè la7d 10 e non ho la
chiave per aprire l'altra porta quindi
ok perfetto mi servirebbe quella chiavi
servirebbe una chiave che la stessa ma
traversa da beta ma non è a destra ed a
mista chiave ho trovato 82 medikit ma
non una chiave porco demonio chi sembra
in catherine league
[Applauso]
[Musica]
macché ma sono vivo sono im attenzione
non so come dio perché mi ha colpito su
una volta sono vivo sono in fin di vita
ma solo viva attenzione attenzione non è
finita ancora lui si alza prende make it
sono ancora in circolazione no sono
morto no sono ancora in circolazione no
è solo un coro tutto qua ecco qua se mi
arriva la zia aretini nome fa un culo
così e lo dico perché oltre i 10 cava
dico mi fai bubi fa un culo così perché
con la pa della mela lancia da un
chilometro in vigna 8 di dieci va bene
ne mancano due ma la zia arrivare qua
tanto non la prendo comoda col casco si
dice in italiano è normale che fa rumore
e quindi capisco da dove arriva
maro perché formare il che fa rumore la
sento
madonna negli altri cessi non c'è niente
dove cacchio star ultima pagina
no mi sentirete un muro
no non è vero come non è vero
va bene
son colonnetti storicamente tra un po ho
preso 8 padellate in bocca da quando
iniziava la partita però è un dettaglio
cioè non fa niente sono infilato
nell'unico punto dove non mi dovevo
infilare stato orribile
però forse riesco a palm è di chi tra
qualche altra parte forze per ogni cane
maremma da mentre cavalcava dammi un
attimo 34 minuti sono se ci fosse stata
l'avrei trovata fidatevi sostato 34
minuti di run è impossibile e noci
poserà veramente impossibile pare bello
però landi da anci levi che vuol dire
ragazza pranzo arrivederci
[Musica]